Yes, my favorite show of 2018 has officially been renewed for season 2 The Haunting of Hill House will return as an anthology season with
the new season
Officially titled the haunting of Bly Manor be sure to stick around for the end of this video because I'm gonna break down the thirty
Second teaser found on the haunting of Hill House's Twitter and you don't want to miss the clues that this gives away
It looks like the crane family will not be returning for season two as carla Gugino told The Hollywood
Reporter that creator Mike Flanagan said he feels like he has told the complete story of the crane family
But don't count the actors out since Flanagan expressed interest in doing something similar to American Horror Story where they come back as new
Characters so even though this will be a new story with new characters
It's possible we could still see the actors who did an amazing job in season one
Returning will we see hell house? It's unconfirmed at this point
But if it does it likely won't play a large role if any at all the theme of season 2 focuses on a new mansion
Entirely fly Manor the setting of Henry James is 1898. Gothic horror
novella of the turn of the screw screw takes place in an old country mansion where two young orphans are looked after by a
Governess who's convinced the grounds are haunted the exact nature of the evil found in turn of the screw is open to interpretation
Similar to how the ghosts in season 1 aren't entirely
Explained now the teaser video currently only available in the hauntings Twitter page States a new haunting is coming
Can you guess where it takes place?
Listen closely if it's based off the novella, then this season will most likely occur in the English countryside
However, it being an adaptation it's possible
They may change the locale to somewhere in the United States Bly Manor also seems to take place somewhere cold the whistling wind and small
Snowflakes seemed to hint that not to mention that turn of the screw starts on Christmas Eve
We then get a flurry of whispers the sound of the floor creaking or perhaps a rocking chair or rocking
horse the quote said by the woman here is from page
35 of the novella
Itself the terrace and the whole place the lawn in the garden beyond it
All I could see of the park were empty with a great emptiness
This is a reference to the governess recounting her experience was seeing a ghost through a window at Bly Manor
She ran outside to catch a better glimpse of it
But upon getting there was met with nothing a great emptiness
the mention of the garden is also
significant by many literature critics who highlight how the story of screw is an allegory for
Adam and Eve and the Garden of Eden with the two children miles and flora being swayed by the ghostly
Entities of Bly Manor like Adam and Eve were swayed by the God and devil and with turn of the screw having children in it
It's likely that some of the amazing child actors from season one may make an appearance
Of course, we won't know for sure until 2020
So make sure you're subscribed to my channel where I'll be dissecting the trailers
Episodes and if you haven't checked out my season 1 analysis
Give it a look until next time catch you in the Red Room and remember daddy loves you very much